[MUSIC PLAYING]
XAVIER DUCROHET: Hello.
My name is Xavier Ducrohet.
MICHAL BENDOWSKI: My
name is Michal Bendowski.
JEROME DOCHEZ: And
I'm Jerome Dochez.
MICHAL BENDOWSKI:
And let us tell you
about down the
Android Build System,
especially a couple of features
that you may not know about.
So let me start with the
performance checklist.
That is all the things that you
should make sure are in order
when you're trying to
improve your build times.
So first of all, please
make sure to use the daemon.
That is already the case if
you're building from Studio.
But if, for some reason, you're
building from the commandline--
like, for example,
when you're trying
to merge your build times, make
sure you use the --daemon flag
or enable it permanently
using the Gradle properties.
Secondly, please make sure to
give the daemon enough memory.
That is especially
important when
using the in-process
texting support that Xav
mentioned earlier today.
You can use the
org.gradle.jvmargs property
to set the heap size
that the daemon will use.
On the other hand, if you find
that your builds are making
your computer
unresponsive, you may
want to limit the total number
of threads that you will use.
And you can use the
android.threadPoolSize property
to do that.
Next, make sure you use
the latest build tools,
specifically 23.0.2 is
the latest one currently.
And it's very
important to use it
because of the fixed
dex merger that Xav also
mentioned earlier.
Get an SSD.
The sad truth is that
building 100 applications
requires a lot of
I/O operations, which
means they actually run a
lot faster on a fast drive.
And lastly, make sure
you don't use timestamps
or commit numbers in your
build files, or at least
not for your debug builds.
I'll come back to it
later in the presentation.
But it's really easy to make
your builds non-incremental
if things are too dynamic.
OK.
As mentioned, please try
the dexInProcess flag.
It's not enabled
by default in 2.0,
but it actually makes
a huge difference.
So please try it and let us
know if it works for you.
Also, consider having
a dedicated development
flavor with minSdkVersion 21.
The API-level 21
introduced some features
that we tried to
emulate at build time
for other devices like MultiDex,
but also vector drawables.
If the MinSdk is
set to 21, then we
have to do less at
build time, which
means the builds are faster.
As we mentioned earlier,
Studio will soon
start to infer the minSdk
number based on the device you
are targeting.
But for now, having such a
flavor is probably a good idea.
OK.
Let's talk about testing now.
I hope you already
know that we support
unit test that execute locally
on your development computer.
But just to reiterate, there
is a dedicated test source
set where you can
put your unit tests.
There is a matching
testCompile configuration
for all your test dependencies.
And we support all the
usual testing frameworks,
although we recommend
you use Unit 4.
There's a separate session
purely about testing right
after this one.
So I recommend you attend or
watch the recording later.
Let me just say that what you
currently aim at supporting
is to allow you to test
your business logic.
That is the part
of your app that is
naturally specific to Android.
Any Android code that you end up
calling will throw exceptions.
So you will have to
refactor your code
to either avoid it or mock
those parts using a library
like Mockito, for example.
OK.
When running JUnit
from the command line,
it's important to
remember that the test
task you may know from
Gradle in Android projects
is actually an encore task that
triggers the real testing tasks
for each variant independently.
So for example, that would
trigger testReleaseUnitTest
and testDebugUnitTest.
Unless your business logic
does something different
depending on the variant,
it's probably enough for you
to just run Gradle testDebug.
OK.
If you need to configure your
test runs-- like, for example,
you may want to increase the
heap size for the test runner.
You can use the testOptions
unitTests.all block.
That will apply the given
configuration closure
to all the variant-specific
test tasks I mentioned earlier.
And it's important to remember
that these settings are not
picked up by Studio currently.
So this is only useful
if you are invoking
test through Gradle,
like, for example,
in a continuous
integration server.
Another testing feature you may
not know about are separate,
dedicated test
projects, which allow
you to keep your main code
and your test code separately,
which can be useful if you need
this additional flexibility
and also if your code
is already organized
this way from the Eclipse days.
The easiest way to get
started with this feature
is probably to copy the template
from the Android Testing
Templates repository.
But let me give you a brief
overview of what's involved.
So the first step is to
set the publishNonDefault
on your main
application project.
And then you create a
separate project that
uses com.android.test plug-in.
You specify which
project you want to test
and which variant
you want to test.
Most likely, you
also want to specify
the testInstrumentationRunner
to be the one from Test Support
Library.
Then you put your testing
code in the main source
set of your test project.
That's something to remember.
And currently, you still have
to put an instrumentation
tag in your test
project manifest
to specify the package of the
application you want to test,
although we hope to get
rid of this step soon.
OK?
And once all of
the setup is done,
you can run the usual
connectedAndroidTest task
on your test project.
OK.
Another issue that
shows up quite often
when people write testing
code is the dependency version
conflict, which,
like, shows up when
you're using the same library
in your main and test code.
So what exactly is
the problem there?
The problem is that at runtime,
your main APK and your test
APK share the same process
and the same class path,
which means they have to use the
same version of every library
even if some of
those libraries were
pulled in as
transitive dependencies
of other libraries.
Like, a common example
is support annotations
in your main APK and then older
version of support annotations
that is pulled in by some
of the test dependencies.
So in this case, we choose
to be very explicit about
what's going on, and we force
you to make a decision whether
you want to change the version
of the library that's used
by your main APK or the version
used by the test APK, which,
in theory, may cause some of
the libraries in this example
runner to misbehave,
although, in practice,
usually they don't.
So the easiest way to solve
this problem when you actually
encounter is to add
another test dependency
to your build.gradle
file that explicitly
depends on the same
version of your library
as your production code.
OK?
And now Xav will tell you
about native supports.
XAVIER DUCROHET: OK.
So starting with the new
version of the plug-in
that we just released, we
have better native support
than we did before.
At I/O, I mentioned a new
plug-in that we're working on,
the model-based plug-in, which
is a new API in the Gradle
build system.
And part of those API is the
ability to build native code.
So without going
through the makefile
that we have right
now in the NDK.
So we made some additional
progress, not a whole lot,
but we are progressing.
So the first thing
to think about
if you want to use it
and try it is that we
have different plug-ins, right?
Normally, it's
com.android.application and
com.android.library.
And now we have--
to replace them,
to use the new
plug-in API, you have
to use
com.android.model.application
and library.
And then we have
a third plug-in,
which is a plug-in that
only generate an .so.
It doesn't generate
anything specific Android.
I mean, that .so is
meant to work on Android,
but there's no Android
packaging around it.
In all three cases, we
directly use the Gradle APIs
to build native code,
but we configure them
with the native tool
chain coming from the NDK.
So the arm tool chain, the x86
too chain, and all of that.
So if you are
using that plug-in,
the DSL a little bit different.
All right?
I think we mentioned
that at I/O also.
And there's some
documentation here.
You should go to that
link and look at it.
But basically, the
biggest difference
is that everything is
under the model element.
And then here, you
can see ndk.with.
Again, the .with is something
we want to get rid of at some
point.
You just define the model name.
And then it will create
a library with that name,
and it will just take care
of everything, basically.
And then under that
NDK element, you
can also configure your
CFlag, your linker flag,
and all of that.
And something new.
So some of that was
already presented
in an earlier version.
Something that was
not presented before
was the ability to do
inter-module dependencies.
So we're now hooking
up with, again,
the new dependency management
that this new Gradle plug-in
API brings.
So you'll be able to do
dependencies like that.
As you can see, it's a very
different DSL from before.
Right?
Before, you had the dependencies
block as a root element.
Here, it's under each
source set element.
So it's a little bit different.
And there's some option, right?
You see that it's not compile,
or debug compile, or anything.
You just say what you
want to depend on.
But you can have
some options on that.
Like, if you want to
do a static linkage,
you would do project library,
and then linkage static,
things like that.
I recommend heavily
that you look
at the documentation for Gradle
itself to see all the things,
because it's an area
that moves a lot.
So you should
definitely look at that.
And then I want to talk about
extending the Android plug-in.
We know a lot of you do
a lot of things in there.
Some of you even create plug-ins
for other people to use.
Every time we
update the plug-in,
we see people using third-party
plug-in being broken up,
because the new
version of our plug-in
is not compatible with
some third-party plug-in.
And it's an area that we know is
becoming more and more painful.
And we want to
solve the problem.
It's not something that we're
going to solve super quickly.
But there's a few things to
look at when you are doing that.
So the first thing is we see
a lot of plug-ins just trying
to access tasks by name.
You know, the plug-in wants
to hook up in some task
and then just do a
get task by name.
And that's just,
like, a problem,
because we're not guaranteeing
that those names are not
going to change.
This is not part of
our official API.
Even Studio does not use
those names directly, right?
In the information that's
really exported by Gradle
through the tuning API,
part of that information
contains the name
of the task to core,
so that in case we
change it in the plug-in,
Studio doesn't
need to be changed.
It just reads the
information from the model.
So you should do the same.
Do not do that.
Now, if you do that for your
own build script, that's fine.
It's your problem to
fix when we break you.
But if you're publishing
plug-in for other people to use,
then you should be
very aware of that.
Another thing to be
aware of, really,
is how the afterEvaluate work.
We see a lot of people who
are very confused about that.
And afterEvaluate is
just basically a callback
that is called after the main
DSL is passed and executed.
And so we register one.
As soon as you do
apply plug-in android,
we actually register one.
And that's where we're going
to create all of our tasks.
And so if you try
to manipulate task
before-- even though I said
you shouldn't, but if you're
doing it, then you
should definitely
do it in afterEvaluate,
because it's not working.
But you can't actually
manipulate other things
in afterEvaluate and task.
If you want to change build
types or do some custom
logic that's going to
change product flavor,
it's kind of too late, because
your own afterEvaluate happens
after hours.
And so you know, it's too late.
You have already
created the variance.
We already created the task.
And it's kind of late.
So the right way, really,
to access our tasks
is through the Variant API.
So we have this DSL, where you
can do applicationVariants.all.
And then you get a closure.
And that gives you access
to the variant, each task,
and all of that.
Now, the trick here
is I just said, hey,
you need to access
task in afterEvaluate,
but that's not in
afterEvaluate, that code.
The trick here is that all.
It's something
specific to Gradle
on the Gradle collection.
And that, basically,
it's register
the closure [INAUDIBLE].
And it will apply that to
all existing and future
item in the collection.
So by the time you call that,
the collection will be empty.
But every time we create
a variant and its task
and we add it to the collection,
then your closure gets called.
OK.
So what can you do
with that object?
You can do some basic things
like greying the name,
for example.
Now, that name is unique.
So it's very useful.
If you want to create
per variant task,
you should use
that name as part,
you know, like foo
plus getName, and then
you know that it's going to
be unique for every variant.
The DirName is one or
more segmented folders.
Very useful to, again,
store your custom task data,
do buildDir/interme
diate/Foo/getDirName
and you know it's unique
for all the different tasks.
You can also get
other information
like the application ID.
That's computed.
It's a merge of
the product flavor
and the suffix in the build
type, and things like that.
You can also get access to the
build types, product flavor.
Those are read-only.
We've seen people change them.
And so a few releases
ago, we actually now
give you a read-only
version of them.
You should not change them.
They are shared across all
the different variants.
So if you're trying
to change them,
you need to change them before
you access the Variant API.
You need to change that
in the regular DSL.
We also give you access
to the task name.
So that's where you want
to go and create the task
rather than doing it by name.
And we know that
a lot of you are
trying to get those
tasks in order
to do things like
inserting steps
in between two different
task and things like that.
And you have to be very careful
about what you're doing there,
right?
I'll go back in a little
bit about the Task API.
But there's some things
that you want to do.
For example, if you're
trying to generate
what we consider
to be source code,
whether that's Java source
code or Android resources,
you shouldn't try to go in and
hook that manually yourself.
We have some entry points
in the Variant API called
Register Java-generating Task.
There's actually some parameter
to that, like your task.
And you should basically have
your plug-in add a new source
folder to the regular Java
source folder list, right?
It's like its multiple
source folder, not just one.
So you can add a new
one to that collection
and then have your task
just write to that,
register your task with
that, and then we'll
call it what it
needs to be called.
Studio will know about it.
And then you know,
it will work end
to end rather than
having you kind
of trying to find
the task manually
and hooking things up together.
You definitely don't want
to go into the javac task
and try to give it additional
source folder there, right?
Just tell us what the source
folder is, give us your task,
and then we'll take
care of things for you.
Now, if you look at
some of the task,
you know, we don't
really have a proper API.
So you may have looked
at our source code
and seen something like that.
It's like, hey, you know,
here's some public stuff,
and here's some private stuff.
Don't use the private stuff.
It will break or
it will break you.
That's why it says PRIVATE.
The public stuff
may break anyway,
because we haven't been very
good about really considering
that a public API.
It's definitely something
we want to do in the future.
And we know that a
lot of people want
to inject stuff between
two particular steps.
And that's between
javac and dx, right?
We know about that.
And so we've been looking at
ways of solving that problem
rather than having you go
and look at the source code,
and see, hey, what
does the dx task do,
and how do I inject it
additional [INAUDIBLE],
or whatever?
So if you look at it here, you
know, that's a default project.
You create it.
It just goes straight
from javac to dx.
And that's easy.
But in reality, you have
additional optional steps
already-- jacoco, which
could or could not run,
and then ProGuard, which
could or could not run.
And then we just
added instant run.
So imagine you trying to add
a couple of other bytecode
manipulation thing and trying
to have to all of that together.
You know, hey, what if I'm
plug in A, and it's plug in B,
so that I can hook
myself separately?
So we just wanted to
fix all that, right?
So starting in 1.5, actually,
we introduced a Transform API
that the goal is to
solve that problem.
So it's just a
pipeline of transforms.
It's not a pipeline.
It's a very steady pipeline.
It's mostly helping us set up
those different optional steps.
We want the API to be
very simple in term
of adding a new transform.
And so it's not
something that you
can manipulate after the fact.
The API doesn't talk
at all about task.
We don't want you to think about
manipulating task, handling
the dependencies between them.
All you have to tell
us is, you know, hey,
what do you want to transform
and things like that.
We take care of
the rest for you.
We do support different types.
So for now on the public API,
we support Java bytecode classes
and non-Android
resources, things
that you would find in a jar.
And it's important, because,
for example, ProGuard
manipulates those.
And we also support dex file.
Though it's not available
through the public API,
we might change that a
little bit in the future.
But for now, that's
not the case.
The way we package and
merge resource libraries
is actually also going
through that pipeline.
And then we support
different scopes.
So for example,
jacoco, we only run it
on the project scope, only
the main app project module.
Instantion also right
now only at project.
But we'll add the submodule to
it, so you'll be able to say,
hey, I want to run
on those two scopes.
ProGuard will run on
all of the scopes,
because it really want
to look at all the source
code of all of it.
So to implement a transform,
we have a abstract class
called Transform.
There's a few
method to implement.
getName.
It has to be unique.
We actually use that to
generate the task name.
getInputType is what you want
to transform, classes or dex.
So ContentType is
actually an interface.
But there's a separate
enum default content
type that contains the
type you can change,
because we have a private enum
for the internal-only types.
Scope is an enum.
And getScope will give you the
scope you want to manipulate.
isIncremental-- whether
your task can or cannot be
incremental.
If you can't really
tell us force,
then we'll optimize some things.
Or we won't do some
work when we call you.
And then finally,
the Transform method.
So you get a context to get
some information about Gradle,
not the task, but a few things.
You get your inputs.
You get some reference
inputs, right?
When we run ProGuard, if
it's in a test app that's
testing something, it needs to
have access to the tested code.
And so the Gradle Transform
actually ask part of the scope
that it ask it has a
getReference scope.
That's not an abstract
method, but you
can implement it anyway.
And you can say it
has a scope that's
called, like, Tested Code.
So you can ask for that,
too, to get access to it.
You're not supposed to touch it.
You're not supposed to write it.
But you can get access
to it to read it.
And then Transform
Method Provider
allows you to create
different type of outputs.
And then whether that particular
run is incremental or not.
And there's some
additional features on it
like secondary file input,
secondary file output.
For about, ProGuard
outputs its mapping file
as a [INAUDIBLE] output,
things like that.
And I encourage you to
look at the Java doc.
So to use it, just do a
dependency on the Transform API
artifact either in your own
plug-in or directly in your
build script.
And then there's
a global, for now,
Android point in the
DSL, a registerTransform.
And then give us the instance.
If you give an
instance like that,
it's a single instance that will
be used for all the variants.
So make it stateless.
But it's fairly easy to do.
So all of those are using the
transform right now since 1.5.
As I mentioned, Jacoco,
ProGuard, the new shrinker,
instant run, dex.
And because dex is
not a transform,
we kind of remove
the regular dex task.
So if you're currently trying
to use accessing the dex task,
you're going to have a problem.
And we want to fix that.
It's not technically gone, but
it will throw an exception.
So in term of order, this
is the order in which
we will run the transform.
And there's no way right
now to change that.
It's really in term of
the third-party one.
There could be more than one.
But it's really first
come, first serve, right?
It's like as you apply custom
plug-ins, that will drive
the order of those transforms.
So we have some limitation.
So as I mentioned,
they are global,
they are not co-variant.
But we do want to
fix that hopefully
for 2.0, for the final version.
And you cannot change the
order through the API.
And it's something we need to
figure out, because there's
some issues, right?
Like, ProGuard will merge
all the scope together
into a single java.
I talked about that
in my other talk
about how it's generating
out a single JAR file.
Then you shrink your dozen.
Then you shrink
your outputs one.
For every scope that it reads,
it outputs a single output.
So if you have something that
needs to read just one scope
and something that merge
all the scope together,
then the order will fail.
So we need to solve that somehow
in the API at some point.
OK.
So that's the Transform API.
Again, the doc is
there, the Java doc.
Go look at it.
Give us feedback.
The API is marked
as beta right now,
because we want to
be able to change it.
Please use it, and let us
know if you run into trouble.
OK.
I want to go very quickly
through inspecting your builds.
We know that this is something
that some people have
a lot of issues.
They don't really
understand what's
going on with their build.
And so there's actually
a few task in Gradle
that will lead you to do that.
The dependencies one
is a standard task.
It's not provided
by our plug-in.
It gives you your
actual dependencies.
So you can see all the
transitive dependencies
and all of that.
It has some interesting features
like showing you which one
gets promoted to a new version.
Just because you have two
version of it in your graph
and one is higher than the
other one, well, in the path
that lower, you
will still see that.
Even though it says
23.0.1, it's actually
using 23.1.1, because somewhere
else, you do depend on 23.1.1.
And then if you have
multiple version
of the same dependency
in your graph,
so it will show that to you.
So for example, here,
support-v4 is used twice.
And so the first time, it shows
you it's transitive dependency.
The second time, there's
a small asterisk saying,
hey, you know, you've
seen that before.
And each one show you the
transitive dependencies.
So that's what that
little asterisk mean.
Now, this will show you
per configuration object.
And if you build your
debug variant, for example,
we actually take the
compile configuration,
we take the debug
and we kind of put them
together, and resolve them
at one, right?
So even though here it's
the compile configuration
and we're resolving to
support annotation 23.1.1, if,
in debug compile,
I'm using 24, then
ultimately, it will use 24.
So you really want to look at it
at the variant level globally.
And so we have these
Android dependencies task
that does just that.
It's at the global-- you
know, that debut here
is actually a full variant.
So you can use that.
We have one for sourceSets.
So I know that
sometime developers
are adding sourceSets.
I'm not sure whether or not it's
actually adding the source sets
and not knowing which
are the folders.
Just look at it.
And then for each, you
see the source set,
you see the actual compile
configuration associated
with it, you see
the actual source
set object that
you can manipulate
in your build.gradle.
So it's very convenient.
And then, finally, we have
the report signing task.
If you're configuring
your signing through it,
you can just do that
report you have.
If you provide it with
a password somehow,
then we can show
the fingerprint.
That can be useful.
And things like that.
All right.
And with that-- thank you.
[INAUDIBLE]
JEROME DOCHEZ: All right.
So let's talk a little
bit about instant run.
I'm not going to give a very
deep, technical description
of how it works.
But I think it's important
that you understand
some of its concepts,
because it may
impact you doing your
iterative development cycles.
So what happened
with instant run
is that you start with a
class that you've loaded
inside your virtual machine.
And that class has many fields
and a couple of methods.
It's loaded.
And as your
application is running,
most likely, you start having
instances of that class around.
And this has been created.
At that point, your
application is running.
But you realize that it is not
running the way you want it.
So you go back to
the ID, and you
start writing code to
change the behavior
of that particular class.
Once you hit the
button, insert run,
we're going to be compiling
just this particular class.
We're going to be dexing
And we're going to be delivering
just this particular classes
to the runtime.
So that's why it's super fast.
So at the runtime
level, we're going
to create a new class loader.
And in that class
loader, we're going
to load what we call
the override class.
So first thing to realize is
that we never actually reload
the Foo class.
The Foo class has
only been loaded once.
And it will be
always loaded once.
Never reloaded.
Instead, it would be loading as
many override class as we want,
because we use a
new class loader.
If you continue writing
more code in this Foo class,
we'll just ditch the previous
version of the class loader
with this override
version, and we'll
have a new one coming in
place replacing the Foo.
So once we have set
up this class loader,
we loaded the Foo
override inside it.
As you can see, all the
methods of the original class
have been moved to static
methods on the override,
and the new code is
actually implemented
within these methods.
Now we just have to
do one more thing.
It's to redirect.
So we redirect from
the original Foo class
every method implementation
to the new one.
OK.
So that's how it works
at the very high level.
Very simplistic demonstration.
But various things
to understand is
this concept of this original
class, which never changes,
and the override class, which
we can change many times.
One other thing
which is important
again is that if you create more
instances of this Foo class,
we're going to be using
the original class.
So the instances
will all be coming
from the exact same class.
And it's particularly
important if you store them
in a collection.
You want them to be of
the same type, right?
So again, remember that
the Foo class will remain,
and all of the instances
that will ever be created
will be from the original class.
What does that mean?
First of all, the override class
will appear in stack traces.
If you generate a
stack trace, let's say
another point to exception
was my own favorite bug,
you will see the override
class in your stack traces.
So you should not be surprised
to see these classes appearing.
We could potentially
remove them,
but we decided that
it's probably better
to not try to mess too much
with the stack tracing,
and leave it.
But you must be aware
that it may appear.
The more subtle
thing that may happen
is that new method
calls only generate--
the new code is only invoked
through new method calls.
That means that if you are
running a particular method,
and you have the while loop
or the for loop inside,
and you change that
class implementation,
it's not going to change
the thread which is actually
running the current
version of the code.
Only when somebody else is
going to code that method will
the new code kick in.
So that's particularly
tricky when you
think about recursive course.
So at first,
recursive course, say,
is going to call
itself 100 times.
The first 10 times
it call itself,
it's the old version
of the class.
Now suddenly, you're
going to swap the class,
and it's going to start
calling the method again.
And because it's a
new call of a method,
it's going to kick in into the
new implementation you just
provided.
So it's going to call itself
90 times with this new code.
But then as it will
come back and unwind
the tail of your
recursive codes,
it's going to come back to the
original method implementation.
So you can see here,
this is getting
into really muddy territory.
And you should be aware that you
could have surprising results
when you start missing,
obviously, the implementations.
The best way, when you think
this kind of stuff happening,
is just to force a
code restart, which
is basically you
stop the application,
and you restart it.
And don't expect this
is going to happen
very often, because there's
not that many recursive codes
or stuff like that
happening in Android world.
But something you
should be aware of.
Again, I already touched it.
Methods are replaced.
Not really classes are reloaded.
We do not reload classes.
I know it sounds like we
are reloading classes,
but we really are not.
We are replacing
method implementations.
So classes are loaded once.
What does that mean?
That means the class
initializer is only run once.
And if you change your
class initializer,
we will flag this as
an incompatible change.
As you know by now, the
instant run technology
is only supporting
basically changing
method implementations.
But if you change a field or
if you had to remove a method,
we will actually restart
the application for you.
Same thing for the
class initializer.
If it changes, we will
restart the application,
because it's an
incompatible change.
Static variables are
not relationized either.
So if you have a class and
you have some static variables
which are not final, and you
started changing their values
through the code,
suddenly you [INAUDIBLE]
that particular class
version to a new version
even if the code that
was actually initializing
these values in
[INAUDIBLE], it's
not going to change the
values of those static fields.
All right?
So you should not expect
things to be reinitialized.
Again, the class has
already been loaded.
It's just going to
continue living its life.
Same thing for instances.
You may have already created
instances of the class
that you are going to update.
And we are not, like,
destroying those instances
or trying to extract
their field's values
and putting them
into some new object.
No.
Those instances stays around.
And the instances fields
remain at the same values
that your application
has already set them.
That's also very true, of
course, for singleton objects.
Again, that's kind
of a situation where
you could expect or you possibly
would expect that because it's
a singleton object,
somehow, we're
going to recreate it with
the new version of the class.
No, we are not.
It's going to be the
same singleton object.
The only difference is that all
of its method implementation
would be redirected
to the new code.
So if you are initializing
the fields of your singleton
object a certain
way, don't expect
it to be reset just
because you changed
the constructor in the
new version of the class.
Sure, the constructor would set
the fields to the new values
if it was to be executed.
But because it's a singleton,
it's not going to be executed.
Therefore, you're going to
get the old field's values.
So it's important to
understand all of this.
At the end of the
day, you should not
worry too much about it.
But it's possible that
sometimes your application
does not really behave the
way you think it should go.
And that's most likely because
maybe the code you've just
modified does not work well with
the state of the application
it's in.
You should just
restart in such cases.
All right.
We also want to talk a
little bit about recipes.
So these are important
things that we would
like to raise awareness about.
And the first one is another
way of generating multi-APKs
which are ABI-specific.
So in the past, when
you wanted to reduce
the size of your APKs, one
of the trick was to say,
I want to have an APK which is
specific to a particular API.
And I'm only going to be
supporting the 86 in this
particular case, where I'm
going to be shipping only
the .so file that are running
for this particular API.
And in this example,
you could also
specify that you wanted a full,
which would have the ability
to run on any possible
devices irrespective
of its particular API.
However, it would be,
obviously, a very big APK.
So in the newer
version, you should not
use product flavors for that.
You should use product flavors
to define your applications
and not how we package
the resulting APK.
And the new way
of doing things is
by using these new splits
declarations inside your model,
inside the DSL.
And the way to do
that is by either
using ABI densities or language,
depending on which type of APK
you'd like.
And what it's going to generate
in this particular case
is four APKs.
Three APKs will be specific to
a particular ABI-- 86, mips.
And one would be the universal
one again, which contains
all the possible API SO files.
This way, you will get a
much smaller APK each time,
and you do not pollute
your product declaration,
the product flavor declaration,
as you had to do before.
Next one is the
Resource Shrinker.
So for many years,
we've had the ability
to shrink the code
using ProGuard.
And that's particularly useful
when you import a library,
and you may be only using 5%
of the library facilities.
You don't want to ship
all the code associated
with that library.
So you use ProGuard, and you
kind of strip all the code
that you're not using.
However, it was not
stripping the resources
associated with that particular
code that is being stripped.
So we now have the ability to
have a resource shrinker that
can piggyback on the
actual program file
to figure out what are
the class that are really
necessary for the application
and which are not necessary,
and make educated
decisions about
whether or not some
resources are necessary.
So when you use ProGuard to
release your application,
you should most likely
always shrink your resources.
And it's going to result
in a much smaller APK
size, which is great for users.
Next one, I think,
is back to Michal.
MICHAL BENDOWSKI: Yep.
JEROME DOCHEZ: Thank you.
MICHAL BENDOWSKI: Thank you.
OK.
This one most of you
probably already figured out.
But let me just talk
about it real quick.
If your project has
multiple subprojects,
it's a very good idea to
share the same versions
of dependencies,
and your SDK levels,
and tools version between
all those projects.
So the way we recommend you
do it is using the Gradle
extensions mechanism.
That is use the ext
block in your root,
top-level Gradle file.
And then inside
this block, you can
create properties to call the
constants you want to share.
You may want to use the Groovy
syntax for defining maps.
So like I did here for deps.
And then you can reference those
values using the root project
prefix in all your
other build files.
OK.
Another tricky part
that sometimes people
are surprised about is the
scoping roles in build files.
So as much as Groovy
scoping has its edge cases,
the basics are the same
as you know from Java.
So the dependencies block in
the current block-- and Xav
mentioned things
are actually a bit
different in the new plug-in.
But in the current plug-in,
the dependencies block
is a top-level property of
the overall project context.
So the fact that you reference
it from some nested call
deep within the Android
block doesn't really
change the meaning
of the call, so
that even if you would expect
this call on the screen
to add a dependency only to the
given flavor, the free flavor,
it doesn't actually do that.
What you should be doing instead
is put the dependencies block
at the very bottom
at the top level
to make it clear
what's going on.
And if you want to add a
dependency only to a given
flavor, you should use
the specific configuration
that we have for this flavor.
OK.
Let's talk about
flavors in general.
I hope you already know that
flavors are a good way for you
to create different
variants of your application
other than build types.
In the next talk,
Jose may actually
talk about how you can
use flavors for testing.
Like, what should you do if
you want to differentiate
your app in more way than one?
So let's imagine you
have a free version
of your app and the
premium version,
but you also want to sell
it in blue and red flavors,
because you believe that will
actually increase the sales.
So instead of creating all
the combinations manually,
what we suggest you do is
use the built-in support
for flavor dimensions that you
have in the Android plug-in.
So you can define one-name
dimensions like price and color
in this case.
Then for every
flavor, you specify
which dimension this
flavor belongs to.
And the additional
advantage of doing it
this way is that you get
dedicated source sets for,
for example, red-only resources,
and blue-only resources,
and premium-only code that
is shared between the premium
red and premium blue variants.
So that's very convenient.
OK.
But what happens if not all
the combinations of build
types and flavors make sense?
At the start of
the presentation,
I mentioned a
development-only flavor.
It probably doesn't
make much sense
to ever combine it with
a release build type,
because we never really want
to distribute the development
variant.
So what we can do is use
the variant filter method
on the Android
block, which allows
you to register a closure.
And the closure will be called
for every about-to-be-created
variant and will be passed
a variant filter object.
You can use this
object to inspect
the build types and the flavors
of the variant in question.
And you can also set
the Ignore flag on it
to indicate that this particular
combination should be skipped.
So you can think of
the variant filter
object of an instance
of such an interface
when there's one setter
for the Ignore flag
and there are getters for build
types, flavors, and the shared
settings from the
default config shared
between all the variants.
OK.
Let's talk about
vector drawables,
which is a feature
we've added in 1.5.
So what vector
drawable support does
at build time is whenever we
find an Android vector drawable
XML file in your
Drawables directory,
we will rename this
file to be within
the anydpi_v21 directory.
And we will also generate
a number of PNG images, one
for each density, for all
the devices to pick up.
You can control the set of
densities that we generate,
so if you don't want to package
load dpi images in your APK,
you can choose to do so.
This setting is per flavor.
So you can have a default set
of densities in default config
and then override it
for a particular flavor.
And you can also set the
set of generated densities
to an empty list set, which will
disable the feature altogether.
OK.
Lastly, since we have
some more time left,
let's just mention
real quick BuildConfig.
BuildConfig is a class that
we generate at build time
for each and every variant.
You can use it to
inspect which build
type and flavor were used to
actually compile your given
variant.
You can use it to, at runtime,
execute different code,
depending on the given flavor.
So for example, you may want
to write an If statement
that checks if
flavor is premium.
And you can also add additional
fields to the BuildConfig class
by using a BuildConfig
field method on build
types [INAUDIBLE] flavors.
So in this case,
if I really want
to hard-code the build date
into my BuildConfig class,
I can do it.
As I mentioned at the
start, I will only
do it for the release builds.
So in the release builds,
I will put a string field
called BUILD_DATE in my class.
The values are pasted as is
into the buildConfig Java source
file, which means
you have to make
sure the quotes are in place.
And here, I assume there is a
formatTime function somewhere
in the build script.
So that will allow me to
actually reference the build
date in my release builds.
For debug builds, I want to
hard-code a constant value,
so that my builds are
actually up to date.
You can imagine that
if formatTime actually
changed every second, my builds
would never be up to date,
because every time I run Gradle,
BuildConfig source would be
different, which means I
would have to compile it,
which means I would have to
redex your entire application
every time just because
this value changed,
which is why we recommend
you do this kind of stuff
only for release builds,
never debug builds.
And if you need to, you can
also define the resValues, which
will do the same thing, but it
would put the values as a value
resource, as a string resource.
OK?
Yeah?
That's it and that's all
we have for you today.
Let's go into the Q&A session.
XAVIER DUCROHET: There's
two mics in the back.
If you want to ask a
question, please go there.
We have time probably for
just a handful of them.
Yup.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about shrink resources.
I see my PNG files are
not in the build APK.
But the IDs are still in
the [INAUDIBLE] Java file.
And it's causing wave
crashes on Samsung devices.
And I saw a solution was
to replace those PNG files
with, like, one-pixel resource.
Can you say something about
that, about shrink resources?
XAVIER DUCROHET: So the
way the shrinker works
is that it looks for code
that uses those IDs, right?
But it is not
removing the R class.
I would be surprised
why, on some devices,
they actually-- like,
if your code does not
reference that ID-- and we're
trying to be very conservative.
There's some cases
where we don't
remove stuff that could be
removed, because we're not
sure.
It's difficult, right?
We just look at the bytecode.
We don't know the actual call.
We just say, hey, 42.
OK, maybe that's a resource ID.
So when we're sure that that
ID is not available anywhere,
we remove it.
So I'm not sure why that would
still be called on some device,
you said?
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: There is
bug report for that.
So.
JEROME DOCHEZ: I seem
to remember that Samsung
was pre-caching and the IDE
would find any application
something like that.
So.
XAVIER DUCROHET: OK.
Yeah, I don't have a good
solution for you, in that case.
JEROME DOCHEZ: I think the
good solution for now is shrink
resource is false. [LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
XAVIER DUCROHET: Yeah.
I mean, we could also rewrite
the R class to remove things.
The thing, also, that you
are doing if you are just
removing the assets, right, we
are not actually removing them
from the Resource table.
So it's possible that
would be a problem.
JEROME DOCHEZ: Right.
So I thought there
was a mode where
we'd put the smallest possible
PNG to replace the actual one,
so that Samsung would be
happy, it would find it.
So but it still doesn't work?
AUDIENCE: I don't believe that
thing is happening right now.
So.
XAVIER DUCROHET: OK.
We should talk about
that after [INAUDIBLE].
JEROME DOCHEZ: We
should talk about it,
because I thought it
was already happening.
XAVIER DUCROHET: OK.
AUDIENCE: Is there
any development
on native dependencies that
would actually also bundle
headers in a case of
native dependencies
that would be deployed to
MVN repository, for example?
XAVIER DUCROHET: No.
I actually don't know.
That's probably more a
question for Gradle, right?
Like, if you have a module that
only outputs a .so-- and I know
you can't have headers, because
the intermodule dependency
supports that at
the Gradle level.
But I don't know what happened
if you tried to publish that
to any sort of repository.
You would have to check
with Gradle itself.
I've seen hands somewhere.
So yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is it possible to
debug why instant run decided
not to do an instant run
on a particular instance--
like, if you changed a
field, it can tell you,
like, it's because you
changed this field?
JEROME DOCHEZ: Yes.
If you add a field
and the instant run
decided that it
needs to restart,
is that what you're asking?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
But I was just
wondering, is there
some sort of logging that'll
tell you why it didn't run?
JEROME DOCHEZ: Yes.
The IDE will tell
you, application
restarted because
you added a field
or because the static
initializer [INAUDIBLE]
because we added a method.
It will tell you.
XAVIER DUCROHET: Is that
a balloon, or is that--
JEROME DOCHEZ: It's a balloon.
When you run, there will be
a balloon that tells you,
restarted because of--
XAVIER DUCROHET: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is there a way,
when you build a debug build,
to make it have a different
package name as a release
build?
XAVIER DUCROHET: Yes.
In build type, there is
something called application ID
suffix.
So if you do any
suffix, it appends that
to your regular package name.
So if you put .debug, then the
debug build will contain that
new package name.
And you can install it side by
side with the release package
if you want.
AUDIENCE: If I have, like,
custom views in XML files,
do those get upgraded?
XAVIER DUCROHET: No.
Then you would have to make a
copy of that particular layout,
put it in the source
debug [INAUDIBLE] folder,
so that you would have a
custom version of that.
We know that it's
something that people
want to have
placeholder in those
and to replace them on the fly.
It's something we will
probably do at some point.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
XAVIER DUCROHET: I think
we are running out of time.
We will be at the office
hours all afternoon,
so feel free to
come and talk to us.
And a fireside chat
also this afternoon
if you want to ask question.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]